hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine right here in
the heart of westminster
well the dust has settled somewhat after
the drama of monday but there is a lot
more settling to go more than 40 of
conservative mps voted to say they have
no confidence in their own prime
minister well for now most of them are
lying low but is that because they're
ready to move on as boris johnson hopes
or are they just waiting for the next
opportunity to strike plenty for us to
get stuck into as we bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
in a long political career so far i have
of course picked up so
barely begun i of course picked up
political opponents all over the place
as always with this prime minister
when he's falling short he just changes
the rules and lowers the bar
well there was plenty of that earlier
today as the leaders clashed in the
commons as this moment hangs heavily
over the prime minister and his party
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
we'll try and assess the state of boris
johnson's premiership and what it means
for the future of the government
and in a slightly different views panel
we're going to be finding out
specifically what conservative voters
make of all the turbulence around boris
johnson's leadership here is our viewers
panel tonight all conservative voters
say quick hello everybody
looking forward to uh seeing you
and speaking to you uh later on we'll
also have some top guests including the
conservative mp tim lowton we'll have
labour's shadow international trade
secretary nick thomas simmons and we'll
be speaking to the former international
trade secretary and the former
conservative chief whip andrew mitchell
much more decides to all coming up on
the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good evening it was a decisive
victory according to boris johnson that
allows us to move on but how easy is
that going to be after the scale of the
challenge from his own mps bigger than
that faced by theresa may john major
even margaret thatcher and that's not to
mention the two by-elections coming up
oh yes and of course the biggest cost of
living crisis for a generation so let's
crack straight on we're going to start
with the best bits of another tumultuous
week
the parliamentary party does have
confidence
[Applause]
thank you by the way everybody for all
your good work yesterday because uh
which was a very important day because
we're able now to draw a line
under the issues that our opponents want
to talk about if
148 of his own backbenchers don't trust
him
why on earth should the country yeah in
a long uh political career so far i have
of course picked up so
barely begun i of course picked up
political opponents all over the place
why did his culture secretary i think
hiding along the bench
say that
successive
successive
successive conservative governments
left our health service wanting and
inadequate
when the pandemic hit
[Music]
mr speaker everybody knows that when the
pandemic hit it was an entirely novel
it was an entirely novel virus for which
the whole world was unprepared oh dear
prime minister
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker
pretending no rules for brooke prime
minister he chunters on pretending no
rules were broken didn't work
pretending the economy is booming didn't
work
and pretending to build 40 new hospitals
won't work either
they want him to change
but he can't
as always with this prime minister when
he's falling short he just changes the
rules and lowers the bar
week after week
i've called on this prime minister to
resign
i've been met with a wall of noise from
the tory benches i thought they were
trying to
shout me down but all this time
[Applause]
but all this time mr speaker it turns
out that 41 of them have been cheering
me on
well it's been a huge week and i'm
really interested to find out what our
viewers panel uh made of it all because
this we're going to do something a
little bit different tonight we're going
to try and find out specifically what
conservative voters make of the votes of
confidence in boris johnson and whether
they think he's the right man to lead
the party so here they all are we've got
six uh conservative voters thanks very
much for being uh with us before we
start i'm interested to know whether you
would have voted to say you had
confidence in boris johnson or if you
didn't so if you were an mp uh putting
your votes in on monday just put up your
hand now if you would have voted to say
you did have confidence in boris johnson
hands up if you do have confidence so
that's four of you i can see there
saying you would have voted to say you
do have confidence boris and johnson and
what about uh everyone else who would
vote to say you did not have confidence
in boris johnson
so two votes there of no confidence so
bit more faith in boris johnson actually
than the mps just about but in both
votes you can see there a majority uh
supporting boris johnson staying on
chloe let's go to you first shall we uh
chloe forrest um you're talking to us
from cumbria uh why do you say that you
still have faith in boris johnson
um i think we've got a look at the
things that he has done right so
you know his health and care levy and
he's put billions of pounds into that
which has got us through the pandemic
ultimately something that nobody knew
about
and so the problems that are being
thrown at him and the things that for
example kia stammer today was saying
that he hasn't done right he actually
has done quite a lot right for the
country and for
the nhs you know along the way on a path
that nobody had any idea about it's
interesting talking about the nhs
because you of course you're a nurse you
know you work through the pandemic you
know you held people's hands um as they
were dying during the pandemic and
what do you make of the partygate
scandal you know some conservative mps
have been unable to forgive that
i think he really he's really messed up
i think where he went wrong
mainly is the fact that he didn't just
tell the truth did he you know he could
have just said i've made a mistake we've
all done it we've all made mistakes
kind of own it and you can get on with
it a little bit easier then i think the
fact that he kind of said he didn't do
it and then he might have and you know
he was going a bit back and forth i
think that's just kind of where he let
himself down a little bit
um but i mean when you look at the good
that he has done as well
um
i think is it the biggest thing
probably not
interesting stuff well let's bring in
roy now shall we roy roy you're talking
to us from uh kent you were someone else
who said that you would vote
uh to keep boris johnson that you still
had confidence in boris johnson um do
you think now we should draw the line
under it
absolutely i mean i've always been
consistent in
the fact that that he is the best of a
bad bunch as far as i'm concerned um and
if we have to take the country forward
we need somebody who has
um
i think we've just just not supine and
that's that's unfortunately where i
okay we're losing you a little bit uh
there roy and we'll come back to if we
can but let's just bring in rob tyler
instead shall we uh rob you're talking
to us from uh bolton you're assigned to
teacher you voted conservative at the
last election do you still think boris
johnson's the man for the job
um i do i think that it's not the time
really for us to do it for new leader
and i think with things going on in the
ukraine and the food crisis the fuel
crisis um i wouldn't like to see a new
eden now um maybe before the next
election uh but i'd like to stepping
down to be at the party's own pace and
not immediate reaction it's interesting
though so you you would you would like
to see a different leader going into the
next election then you think why is that
potentially i think that may be a new
leader unturned by by the current issues
that have
dogged the current uh incumbent of uh
number 10
could
serve the conservatives better for the
next election and do you think that's
because they might do better electorally
yes if if the right lead is picked i
think i think we could actually do much
better at the next election i think we
can build on what we've already got and
with the right choice um
i think we could actually build i think
we could do better the next election
than we've already done interesting
stuff anyone in particular bring spring
to mind
um yeah tom cuban
interesting stuff interesting choice
there right let's bring in uh john comma
for shall we uh now uh you are talking
to us from uh kent you voted
conservative at the last election would
you vote for them again this time around
with boss johnson as leader
no i wouldn't
and why is that
i just don't trust the man frankly and i
voted conservative all my life
and i'm very disappointed with the way
he's behaved i really do believe he
should have resigned i know people i
agree with chloe and one or two other
people who've said he's done some good
things but he's led a lot of people down
and particularly people that couldn't
say goodbye to their loved ones people
who couldn't visit their loved ones in
hospitals they were
in the process of passing away so you
know i just can't support that sort of
man it's interesting you um sort of talk
to our team a little bit about your own
experiences of the pandemic how you know
you didn't leave your house you couldn't
say
goodbye to relatives at their funerals
is there is that that sort of personal
experience why you feel so strongly
i do feel strongly my
situation is a lot better than
than many other people during the course
of the panda pandemic but uh at the end
of the day um
if the man is making
the walls he should stick by them and i
don't really believe he's done so with a
clear conscience would you vote
conservative with a different leader
oh most certainly i've heard a
conservative all my life and
i wouldn't even think about
not voting conservative but i will not
vote for boris johnson and there's
another party that you would go for or
would you just not vote at all
i just wouldn't vote at all which at my
age having voted ever since i was 18
years would actually disturb me but i
think at the same time um you know i
wouldn't want to support another party i
am a conservative voter i would always
be a conservative voter but not my
buyers johnson is in control interesting
stuff and let's talk to paul blom now
shall we paul i know that you were
another one of our panelists who said
that you would have voted
no confidence in boris johnson um just
explain why
well i've never been a massive fan of
boris johnson um at all
i was a remainer i would like to remain
as i never agreed with his uh policy
about leaving the eu
um
it's been generally accepted as a flawed
character um and uh you know he
i thought perhaps he might change when
he became prime minister but he
obviously hasn't
he doesn't show any integrity i think
it's all about him rather than anything
else
i don't really think he's got the
qualities to be a prime minister
would you vote conservative at the next
election if he was leader
um
tough question i probably would
but i probably would but i mean the
other thing you know people make out
that he got such a big majority at the
last election but
i think you have to consider in the
context of of the election and who
the alternative was
um i've actually seen i think the
cardboard box was standing against
jeremy corbyn he would the car box would
have gone into 10 towning streets
um
so i'm a little bit cynical about you
know his big no he's being praised for
the big majority that he got
interesting stuff well let's bring in
here's a campaign
so sorry what were you saying
and i was saying i mean he's a good
campaigner you know he you know um but
he's not a details man and i think you
need to be a prime minister you need to
be a details person interesting stuff
well let's bring in vic daniels now
shall we uh vic
you told us that you would have voted to
have confidence uh in boris johnson um
do you think that are you frustrated i
guess with the mps for voting a
different way
i can understand that but um in one
sense um but
you you started off by asking earlier
you know is he the right man or woman to
do the job and i think the problem is
that he's the only man or woman that can
do the job
um you know if if we really want the
conservatives to form the next
government there's only one person that
can can lead the party and that's boris
he's a lucky politician and i think you
can't underestimate estimate that
um you know he's got brand recognition i
think the word is uh mononymous where
you're so famous that you can be known
just by one name your first name you
know so it's boris you know if you said
dom or liz or ben or jeremy it's not
gonna mean anything but um the very fact
that he's got that brand recognition i
think being a lucky politician he'll
probably he'll probably just about get
over the line next time so you think
that he's gonna lead the party into the
next election then if he's got all this
luck on his side
i think he will and i think he'll win
okay and let's just go back to roy shall
we because we lost you last time didn't
we roy uh just talk to us quickly about
um
your feelings about the confidence vote
why do you think boris johnson is still
the right man
um because he has chutzpah the the rest
i i just think a supine they they will
um
they they lack the big picture and you
know one of the other commentators said
that he's he's not a details person
it's not a details person we need we
need somebody with a grand vision really
to as to where the country should be
going in the next five 10 15 years and
not just concentrating on the next
news cycle which is where i think over
the last 24 48 24 36 months is where the
country has been um politicians have
been have been gravitating towards what
the next
news interview is going to be on on on
broadcast media um
and that's been the problem i think and
that's that's why brexit didn't happen
in the way it should have happened um
and and why we
made certain mistakes i think during the
pandemic right just to end um i asked
you to have a piece of pen and a paper
i'm hoping this is going to go smoothly
we'll have to see um if you could write
down on your piece of paper the name of
the person you would like to see
leave the conservative party into the
next general election so it could be
boris johnson it could be another
candidate um who do you think is the
person you would like
to see
lead the conservative party into the
next election we're getting a couple in
now i can see
roy has gone for boris
rob's gone for tom tuggin hats
i can see paul has gone for ben wallace
or tom tugging and hat said that name
again
chloe's gone for sanjay javid
john can you just move your paper a
little bit further away jeremy hunt that
is
uh and then vic daniels who have you
gone for
have you got your piece of paper ready
can you hold it a little bit further up
up up up
a little bit further boris okay another
for boris johnson perfect well that is
interesting because i think that even
though the majority of you guys would
have voted to have confidence in boris
johnson only two of you say that he's
your preferred candidate for the next
election really interesting
plenty for number 10 and the wider
conservative party uh to think about uh
there and we can speak now to
conservative mp uh somebody who has uh
publicly called for the prime minister
to uh go thank you so much for being on
the programme tonight uh tim lauten
who is a former uh children's minister
in the uh department for education
conservative mp for east worthing and
shurim joins us now thank you for being
with us pleasure um so how did you vote
on monday and why
i would regret voted that i didn't have
confidence in
in boris i made my position clear way
back in january that i thought his
position had become untenable i don't
think anything has happened since then
to change that view probably the uh the
reverse
so without making a fuss about it
without leaving lots of interviews and
writing articles about it uh i said to
my constituents who asked that i would
vote that i had no confidence with
regret the vote happened the vote went
the other way we accept that vote and
move on it's interesting as you say you
know you haven't done much media around
it you you made your position clear
um you say you want to move on um does
that mean you're ready to just draw a
line under it you want boris to borrow
johnson to lead the party into the next
election well
the problem is i don't think this is
going to end it um we've we've had a
clear vote and we must abide by the uh
the rules i absolutely respect that uh
that result the prime minister remains
the prime minister and the leader of the
the conservative party
but that's not ended it this has gone on
for over six months i can't think of any
other problem that has overhung a prime
minister or a government and you're
talking about the first time effectively
the whole part again this started way
before um christmas if you uh if you
remember we've still got the privileged
committee report to come out at some
stage we've still got the reporting to
the whole handling of uh kovid
uh and you know various other things are
still going to come out of the next few
weeks what's going to happen with
kirsten if kerastama were to be given a
fixed penalty notice it makes the
parents position look a bit uh doubtful
as well so i don't think i fear this
isn't going to draw a line under it so i
think the prime minister's got a big job
of work to show that he's back at the
helm he needs to absolutely rally around
the party and build a unified party have
some changes in the in the cabinet
rather fewer people saying yes of course
boris and a few more saying are you nuts
prime minister would be helpful
um if he can do that he might just start
to win back the confidence but there's a
big question mark over there so you'd
like to see a reshuffle effectively with
people who are prepared to stand up to
him a bit more i i think we need to have
a cabinet as we've had before if you go
back to mrs satcher's time she didn't uh
surround herself with yes men and women
aren't any women it was people that she
fundamentally disagreed with but would
take them on people who would say to her
are you sure that's what you want to do
actually i think you're wrong and she
would say well i think i'm right and
this is why we need more of that sort of
debate in encampment we need far more
backbenchers there's huge talent on the
back benches who are not playing any
parting government at the at the moment
who have got a lot to offer so i think
boris has got to absolutely extend a
hand of friendship and be much more
inclusive to many more people in the
party where there is a lot of talent
that's not being used is there any names
that you would give us for examples of
those kind of no but no no because then
you will start getting into um arguments
about why him and not her or or whatever
um i think backbenchers feel a bit
neglected and i think the clear-up that
happened in number 10 had to happen but
it hasn't gone um far enough we need to
be
talked to a lot more we need to be
consulted about policy a lot more and we
don't need this problem where we're
marched up to the top of the hill to
defend things which are
a bit tricky indefensible some would say
some would say indefensible only for 24
hours later number 10 to do a complete
u-turn and we marched all the way down
again these are the sorts of things that
undermined confidence in even david
cameron and theresa may um previously so
we've got a huge challenge facing us the
country's got a huge challenge with the
cost of living that crisis with the
continuing issues around ukraine and
lots of other other things we need
absolutely just be focused on that and
delivering for the people not having
debates amongst ourselves about whether
our leader is up to being leader or not
are there policy changes that you would
like to see as well
well i don't think this is largely about
policies if you look at previous prime
ministers that were got rid of
poll tax mrs thatcher started the the
slide there
this hasn't been about policy
i'm afraid it's been about the way the
prime minister has personally handled
what started as a party gate and for me
it was never about how many glasses of
warm chardonnay were quaffed in downing
street or sausage rolls eaten it was
about the way it was handled
um and that then became the issue rather
than the so-called parties them that
themselves and by the way it was handled
do you mean um lack of contrition or or
not really accepting well i think a lot
of contrition and i think as one of your
panelists actually said earlier if he at
the beginning had actually owned it and
said
actually i think we've we might have um
committed some offenses here actually i
didn't realize but in retrospect um i
think we shouldn't have done it this way
and so we need to investigate if we've
actually committed any
crimes um at all and absolutely owned it
from the start i think he put his hands
up rather than trying to say no no
nothing went wrong there were no parties
oh there were parties but they're all
within the rules and oh but i wasn't at
any of these parties but then actually i
might have been a party and that just
the credibility just just drifted that
was the problem so getting back that
that confidence of people that his
integrity is in uh intact uh and that
he's capable of carrying on with this
job is going to be a big big challenge
but people want to see a prime minister
and the government getting on with the
job of the challenges facing everybody
in their everyday lives which are
considerable i just wonder what you make
of the prime minister's reaction to the
confidence vote he's described it as a
very good result and decisive victory do
you think he gets it well he clearly
wasn't i mean the margin was much
tighter than most people had expected
and certainly he had uh had wanted and
again i think he needs to own that i
think he needs to say look okay we have
got a problem which is why i think he
needs to bring people inside the tent
who have opposed him in some cases uh
candidates who stood against him who
frankly should have been in the cabinet
right from the uh from the start to try
and get unity together again and get
those people firing all cylinders of the
jobs that all those cabinet ministers
need to be doing in a government that's
delivering for the people
i'm quite intrigued as to
whether or not some of the rebels are
likely to have another go
according to the current rules of the
1922 committee the prime minister now
can't be challenged for a year but of
course those rules can be changed
is that an active discussion
no and i think what's different about
this there's a really interesting piece
in the times by william hague yesterday
about uh when there are plots to get rid
of of leaders this wasn't an organized
one where there was a clear alternative
contender this was quite a few people
who were a bit discontented you know
like like me and others thinking
actually we've got to do better than
this there wasn't so some organized
campaign i think the few people like to
claim that they were running organized
campaign it didn't actually um happen
like that the rules are the rules we've
had a result under the rules that result
stands it doesn't look good if within
days of that result you tried to start
changing the rules so i'm not really
interested in that
if the prime minister absolutely
realizes that his position continues to
be untenable as some people have said
and i said back in january then it's for
him to make the decision to resign until
there could possibly be a challenge a
year out we're getting closer to an
election
people don't elect parties that are
divided we need a strong clear leader
with strong leadership
with a good solid cabinet and ministers
firing on all cylinders that's his
challenge in the next few weeks if he's
to stand any chance of going to next
election as the leader of the
conservative party and prime minister
what do you think his chances are of
going into that election i i honestly
don't know it's really difficult to uh
to tell because all sorts of things have
happened in the last few months that
have come out of come out of nowhere um
and i think if there are more party gate
type
mishaps to put it mildly um then his
position becomes more more um untenable
you know the trouble is this time many
of us have people writing just saying
that
the behavior that promises has been
absolutely disgraceful but they've said
that about the last conservative prime
minister or anything the conservative
government does there's been quite a few
actual conservatives who said look i've
voted conservative all my life and i
know they're conservatives my
constituency and i can't do so
absolutely so he's got to be able to win
those people back
to stand a fighting chance of being a
successful leader to win the next
election for us and the jury is out on
on that but he's the leader we've
reelected him as the the leader we need
to get on with the job of him as prime
minister by government that's doing
stuff that's outside of westminster not
looking on ourselves okay fascinating to
talk thank you very much for coming on
the program uh tonight
uh well a little bit later we will get
labour's take on all of that but first
we can have a little chat and work out
what we've learned so far we're joined
by our deputy political editor sam copes
hi sam um
interesting stuff on the panel first of
all four out of the six saying that they
would have voted to have confidence in
boris johnson but then the majority
picked a different candidate to lead the
conservatives into the next election
that was fascinating was it and i think
that captures
the difficulty that many conservatives
are finding in trying to work out try to
navigate the complexity of the situation
that we've got at the moment and and i
thought it was interesting from from tim
latin as well
because
on the one hand he was saying we've just
effectively re-endorsed boris johnson
there's got to be a path for redemption
and he set out some criteria but those
criteria sounded incredibly difficult
for boris johnson to actually satisfy
bringing new voices new names into a
cabinet which he effectively said was
weak but also restore integrity when tim
laton himself were saying well well
effectively you've got somebody lied
about partygate
and he needs to change his style
people ask is boris johnson going to
survive
i think for him to be toppled there's
got to be more of a sense amongst the
rebels of how that might happen i wasn't
clear from tim if that was going to be
the case when that might happen could it
be after the by-elections could have
been later there's no agreement about
that
and they've got to decide who
and that is also deeply unclear and
that's the problem we've had such a
disparate group of
people and factions and personalities
voting against him so many people and
none really there is no
uh name that i think anyone coalesces
about for when conservatives voted on
monday they weren't voting what it was
said on the ballot paper they weren't
voting about whether or not they had
confidence in boris johnson they were
trying to work out whether or not
keeping boris johnson would be better or
worse than having a messy leadership
contest exposing all of the divisions
that exist inside the conservative party
be they personal and be they policy and
then a new leader who might not be as
good as boris johnson was in 2019
or keeping the incumbent as damaged as
he is interesting stuff and he also did
say that he had weeks i think to try and
sort that out sam thank you very much
indeed for your analysis
you're watching the take we are live
here in westminster up next we're going
to be talking to labour's shadow
international trade secretary nick
thomas
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the take now for labor
it must be tempting to sit back and
watch the conservatives tear themselves
apart over boris johnson's
leadership but the opposition does face
questions itself especially how it would
respond to the ever deepening cost of
living crisis we can speak now to
labour's shadow international trade
secretary nick thomas simmons thanks
very much for being with us today
i mean what an extraordinary week it's
been um 40 of conservative mps voting to
say they've had no confidence in their
prime minister
do you think kirsten missed a bit of a
trick at prime minister's questions not
really pushing that
no i thought that kia stammer at prime
minister's questions today actually
pushed the reality the people are facing
in the nhs in england unable to get a gp
appointment the weights at a e
the cancer waiting list that have been
going up over the past 12 years that's
the reality people are facing
and we have a government now that isn't
dealing with those issues what we've
seen this week is a government in
absolute chaos we have 148 conservative
mps who agree with us as an opposition
that they've no confidence whatsoever in
the prime minister then you've got 211
conservative mps who are saying that the
prime minister's law breaking the prime
minister's contempt for people's
sacrifices during the pandemic is an
acceptable thing that they can support
what you now have is a divided
conservative party that isn't going to
be able to tackle the challenges of the
country
do you think though i mean boris johnson
argues that look he he's got the vote
out of the way he's drawn a line under
it he's got a majority and actually you
know even if you speak to the most
fierce critics like tim lowton who just
had on the program they seem to accept
the result and do you think that he's
now going to lead the conservatives into
the next election
uh whether the prime minister leads the
conservatives into the next election uh
or not we will be making the case that
we've had 12 years of conservative
failure and looking at it from the
opposition benches this week let's not
hide from what's happened here a
majority of the conservative mps has
voted to support this prime minister
this is a prime minister whose focus is
on saving himself this is the government
we saw a document conservative mps had
put around saying that the purpose of
this government is actually to keep the
prime minister in office they are not
focused on the problem i mean to be fair
they would say that you know in just the
last few weeks they have they have
launched a bumper package to help with
the cost of living going further than
the labour party would have done uh on
uh with the windfall tax and on energy
bills so
it's not right to say that they're not
doing anything is it the conservative
party has been in power for 12 years is
tired and out of ideas it's labor that's
made the political weather it's the
windfall tax proposal that we actually
pushed for months and months and if by
the way they'd adopted it five months
ago nearly six months ago when we first
spoke about it people would have been in
a much better position now they are out
of ideas and this is a tired government
now on the 21st of june we're expecting
strikes on the trains or on the
underground network the rmt say that
it's going to be the biggest outbreak of
industrial action in the uk since 1989.
do you back the strikes
what i would like to see is a resolution
to this nobody ever wants to see strikes
nobody wants to see workers in a
position of making those sacrifices
nobody wants to see the disruption that
this is going to cause to the public and
what we need to come in there because i
mean no one would disagree that you want
to see a resolution the question is you
know where do you get that resolution if
you can't reach one would you like
strike so do you back strikes under the
current situation what i want to see is
more dialogue we've seen the three dates
that the rmt has spoken about there is
still absolutely time for dialogue that
dialogue has to take place and we can't
have either government ministers somehow
washing their hands of responsibility
about this so more dialogue does that
mean that the rmt should pause the
strikes in favor of more dialogue is
that what you're saying but there's
still time available we're not right up
against at the moment the date that the
rmt is saying i think it's the 21st of
june is the first date that they're
talking about there is time for dialogue
we need to get all the parties around
the table needs to be the government by
the way not distracted permanently as
they are by their own internal problems
who actually take some responsibility
for facilitating these talks and
preventing that strikes from happening i
spoke to the rmt's mick lynch on the
sunday program a couple weeks ago
he said i've seen no response from the
labour front bench that says we support
the workers in their struggles if we
just get this bland democratic party
sitting in the center of politics taking
their instructions off the daily mail to
some extent and not actually getting
behind workers struggles you have to ask
yourself why do they actually call
themselves the labour party well i don't
agree with that
interpretation we are on the side of
working people up and down the country
whether they're working in the rail
industry whether uh they are in the
wider public working in uh many other
industries what we need to see is an
actual cost of living package we need an
emergency budget we shouldn't be having
the national insurance increase can you
see why mitt lynch thinks that the
labour party is a bit bland if you just
say oh yeah we want more dialogue but
it feels like you're not really giving a
definitive answer on what you feel about
the strikes
no i fundamentally disagree because i
think strike action is always difficult
and dialogue is the only way that you
find a solution so that's why i'm
merging that dialogue in those
particular circumstances but i don't
accept at all that what we said about
the cost of living is somehow bland it's
our campaigning on the windfall tax
that's caused the government to actually
have to adopt our policy we are the ones
calling for an emergency budget saying
there shouldn't be the national
insurance increase we're the ones who
are talking about investing a climate
investment pledge 28 billion pounds uh
each year insulating homes up and down
the country we are the party that is
putting those ideas forward do you
support the government's package on the
cost of living
uh
we've we've been very clear on things
like where the chancellor actually
reduced fuel duty that of course those
are things that we would support but the
idea that what the chancellor has put
forward is sufficient for everybody out
there is actually facing i'm afraid it's
for the birds it isn't and what the
chancellor has had to do already was to
come back when we pushed him to do so he
should come back again with an emergency
budget but with what in the the
emergency budget what specifically would
you like to see right well first of all
let's see the reversal of the national
insurance increase
let's see the chancellor of the
exchequer take away vat on energy for
example is another thing that the
chancellor could do and let's see the
chancellor as well
for once actually have a long-term plan
for tackling growth in the in the 10
years before the pandemic the average
growth per year was running at below 2
percent there needs to be a strategy in
my area of international trade by the
way we see the government rushing to
complete uh initial trade deals what
they're not doing and i see it because
they're visiting exporters on the front
line they're not providing the support
to businesses and to exporters that they
need to actually be able to make those
trade deals work for communities up and
down the country okay thank you very
much for being on the show today uh nick
thomas simmons uh there
now of course the question that everyone
is asking here in westminster is what
next for the conservatives who voted
against boris johnson will they accept
the results and move on will they demand
forrest johnson makes policy changes or
perhaps reshuffles his top team as tim
lowton was saying earlier or will they
try and find another way of changing
leader before the next general election
our political editor beth rigby spoke to
david davis and aaron bell a little bit
earlier to try and find out she started
by asking if the conservatives could win
a general election under boris johnson
well i think if he does these changes
yeah we have a decent chance i mean you
know we're two years away so it's
hard to say but if we don't do them i'm
reasonably sure we won't win that's
that's the issue people
you might change your mind on him well
if if he does the right thing in the
next year but he's got to do the right
things the next year because that's the
time which will deliver in time for an
election you know if people are not able
to live their normal lives ordinarily
you know with reasonable chances of
getting things done reasonable chance of
earning money enough money to spend that
sort of thing that's what they'll judge
on they won't be judging frankly on
gossip column issues in two years time
they'll be judging on how they and their
children and their parents are getting
on how the state's looking after them
and and how the ordinary day-to-day life
is working we've got to fix lots of
things in that area boris can provide
the leadership to do that but he's got
to set out to do it not just big
decisions it's a whole spectrum of
leadership has he got the right team
around him though in the cabinet well
that's he's going to make that call i
mean he should be he should be looking
the sort of things i've been listening
and saying why is this not being put
right why has this been let go wrong you
know who has not done their job and has
to change them for people who will do
the job it is a trying time when parties
are having these internal disputes and
that's why i would like to see us pull
back together again and i'd like to see
the prime minister reach out to some of
the people who did vote against him and
then find a way to bring some of them
into government and find a way what does
that look like i don't know it's not up
to me i mean i'm not asking from your
point well i'm certainly not asking for
a job myself um but i do think that it
would be helpful if uh that the top team
reflected the vote let's put it like
that
what do you mean i guess i mean that
there should be
some representatives of the kind of
people that have felt
left out by this government you don't
get 148 votes from nowhere
well my seat right now is if you look at
the calculus you know websites and so on
he's on a knife edge
so i have got a vested interest in boris
johnson turning this round that's why i
would like to see him do that
now it's a regular chance to speak to
about ventures we pick our prime
minister's question of the week it's
something a little bit different that
caught our eye during the session
earlier and today
it was this one is he aware that there
are five alleged rwandan war crimes
perpetrators living freely in the uk
who have been doing so now for 16 years
and have neither been extradited or put
before the british courts under our
existing laws
as he prepares to go down to the
commonwealth heads of government meeting
in rwanda will he look carefully at this
issue because it is bound to be raised
with him
well now of course usually the
questioner doesn't get a chance to
respond to the prime minister's answer
we're trying to put that right so which
week letting that mp do just that so
that question uh this week was from the
concert mp andrew mitchell he's a former
international trade secretary once the
conservative party chief whip as well so
knows where all the bodies are buried he
joins us now and thank you very much for
being with us
um just explain uh a little bit about
why you decided to answer that question
today
well i came up on the reshuffle in the
shuffle uh so i obviously asked i tried
to get a question every week and it's
actually over a year since i got a place
on the order paper so it seemed to me a
good thing to do ahead of head of the
commonwealth government uh heads of
government meeting and for this reason
that the government has been very strong
quite rightly on going after the war
criminals who are perpetrating these
atrocities in ukraine but
for 16 years now these fugitives from
rwandan justice who are alleged
perpetrators of
hideous war crimes have been living in
plain sight in the uk
16 years neither extradited as the
rwandans wished nor tried under british
laws these are terrible crimes in which
they are accused and of course in africa
many people say well this is because
they're not white europeans the british
judicial system the british don't care
about the fact that these are murdered
black africans they only care about
white europeans that's why they take
such a strong line in ukraine and as a
as a british member of pond i'm very
offended by that but the evidence is
there on the table 16 years they've not
been sent back to rwanda as so many
other countries have done with those who
the rwandan government have sought to
extradite and they're not being tried
under the british system either and the
police say it will take years and years
to address this point and it isn't good
enough and it's very bad for britain's
international reputation and what did
you make of the prime minister's
response to your question
well i mean you know he he he he's not
obviously very familiar with this issue
but he promised that he would get
familiar with this issue and that was my
aim and purpose that when he goes down
to rwanda undoubtedly you know the
president of ryan will say to him you're
very happy to send your asylum seekers
here why aren't you uh either
prosecuting in the uk or sending back to
rwanda these people who are alleged to
have committed the most terrible crimes
against our citizens you mentioned there
the deal uh struck between the uk and
rwanda to send asylum seekers to rwanda
the first plane due to leave next week
but of course it's had this challenge
in the high courts and do you think that
policy needs to be dropped
well i i think that the rawannas have a
very good reputation for helping out
with humanitarian situations they have
taken peop desperate people who were
caught off the coast of libya from the
struggle there and give them a new life
in in rwanda and the rwandans are trying
to be helpful in a humanitarian way they
did the same thing for the israelis but
my issue with the policy is that i don't
think it will work and it's incredibly
expensive for the british taxpayer i'm
not opposed to
britain if someone comes here illegally
seeks asylum is processed in the uk and
is then turned down for asylum if if
then the british wish to deport them to
rwanda and rwanda is willing to take
them i wouldn't i wouldn't be against
that but this is a policy which will be
extremely difficult to implement will be
hideously expensive for taxpayers and i
just don't think it will work that's my
main objection
how popular do you think these kind of
policies are with the electorate it felt
like for years in a way and being tough
on immigration was being seen as a bit
of a badge of honour something that
would always go down well with with the
population uh at large do you think
that's changed well i think you know i
think that this is uh
i think this has brought up a lot of
people up short it's just not the sort
of thing we would normally do and and
actually you know there's no alternative
but to do the hard yards of processing
people properly employing more staff to
process them when they get here having a
better relationship with the french i
mean you can't do anything about the
core problem which is people coming
across the channel in a leaky boat
putting themselves into the hands of the
modern day equivalent of the slave
trader you've got you've got that's the
prime problem you've got to have a deal
with the french so so that's the second
thing you need to do and you need to
revise the
1951 geneva convention on refugees
because that was set up before there was
mass travel before there was climate
change driven migration um and and
there's no there's really no alternative
uh but to do those hard difficult things
if you're going to get this problem
under control and say you're going to
ship a few of them off halfway around
the world you know it's it's not very
nice and it's not really the way britain
does these things another policy where
you need to do the hard yards is what's
happening in northern ireland and the
impact of the northern ireland protocol
there and lots of people extremely
concerned about it the whole
administration of course not up and
running until it is sorted now the
government is claiming that it's legal
for it to act unilaterally to change
parts of the protocol um do you think in
your view it is well i'm not a lawyer so
i i don't know i would rely on
independent uh legal advice on that
point but uh i do think that the
european union is being extremely
difficult i think they need to be much
more sympathetic and understanding about
the issue of the border in northern
ireland and the problem this is creating
which which we do not want to imperil
the peace agreements that have been set
in in northern ireland uh and i've been
in the house comments long enough to
remember those terrible statements made
after atrocities took place you know we
need to honor the agreements that have
been reached so i think the eu need to
be more sensitive but equally you know
you don't sign a big international
treaty and then a few months later
decide you want to go back on your word
and the last thing britain needs now
when our economy is so stretched at the
moment and there are these huge
difficulties with the cost of living is
to have a trade war with europe where
the americans our closest ally are on
the side of europe so this is a time now
for very cool heads very good
negotiation and a real understanding by
both sides of the issues here but but i
do think the european union is not being
as helpful or as sensitive to these big
international problems as we have a
right to expect
now of course uh this week i think 41 of
conservative mps voted to say they had
no confidence in boris johnson you were
one of them
what would you like to see from boris
johnson going forward to
get your trust back on him
well i think he needs to govern in the
same way he did when he was mayor of
london he needs to
uh
up his game as prime minister and the
problems he's seeking to address i think
i think there's a whole range of things
he needs to do there's a lack of
coherence and a lot of policy these are
very big issues to do with energy costs
the cost of living inflation growth you
know the critical thing in the british
economy is to increase the level of
growth and we need a laser-like
attention from the prime minister and
you know if 32 colleagues change their
minds he will be out of office but uh we
need to get on with tackling the
problems that my constituents have sent
me to westminster to try and address and
not go on about this day after day do
you think there could be another vote
then you said that it just tick nick's
another 32 to change their minds well
there won't be another vote at the
moment for a year and we've got to
respect the conventions that says things
stand but there's there's a lot of
events you know in politics it's events
which come around the corner and
surprise you
and the key thing is he's got to get on
with the job now of delivering the best
possible
answers to these very very serious
problems and this sort of lack of grip
on policy has got to be addressed okay
thank you very much for being on the
program today thank you andrew mitchell
there
you're watching the take we are live in
westminster next we're going to round up
everything we just heard and do a bit of
post-match analysis with our deputy
political editor
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
after a pretty tumultuous week you are
watching the take
we've had lots of takes uh this evening
uh time now for our regular post match
uh roundup with our deputy political
editor at sam coats who's with us here
sam what i'm really intrigued by is you
know we've we've heard from you know our
panel we've heard from concert for mps
where is number 10 at
well i think that number 10 have a
massive decision to make now you heard
on your show all of your interviews uh
the people at beth rigby was talking to
the rebels all saying boris jones has
got to change his style widen the tent
bring in some of his critics the
question is will he yesterday sky news
did a survey and we discovered that
there are 12 ministers and ministerial
aides still in government having not
even said in public that they back boris
johnson and the test for boris johnson
the question
is is he pragmatic and inclusive and
does he keep these people in government
or is there an element of revenge does
he start sacking in a reshuffle sooner
or later the kind of people who weren't
standing solidly behind him so where is
he well i'm hearing reports of mps that
were rebels going up to him yesterday at
events uh asking him how he was and the
prime minister saying i'm fine no thanks
to you and walking off or one ally tory
mp of the prime minister going and
seeing him in his office only to find
boris johnson asking them did you vote
for me can you prove it now all of that
points to a mindset of a prime minister
who feels wounded who feels hurt i
suspect the big decision of being
inclusive or taking revenge hasn't been
taken yet but we're just gonna have to
wait and see fascinating and really as
you say goes against the calls of aaron
bell of tim lowton to see
some of people critics effectively being
brought into the tent uh perhaps
unsurprising for a prime minister who
often
values loyalty among other qualities sam
thank you very much that is it for the
take this week we'll be back next week
and every week wednesday at 9pm next up
it's sky news at 10 thanks for watching
[Music]
you